[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
we have truly horrific news to start
with today the worst mass shooting in
modern American history was in the early
hours Eastern Time today around 10:00
p.m. Pacific time last night Sunday
night in Las Vegas Nevada where a gunman
opened fire this was at an outdoor
country music festival sort of alongside
the Mandalay Bay
Hotel and even though this was not a
crowd that was at Mandalay Bay it was
close enough to Mandalay Bay that the
gunman was actually on the 32nd floor of
the Mandalay Bay Hotel in Las Vegas and
so far and the numbers have already
shifted drastically over the last four
or five hours over 50 killed is the
number that we have and more than 400
injured so far and there were numerous
off-duty police officers who are
believed to be among the dead and the
injured and the gunman has been
identified and is no longer alive the
gunman identified a 64 year-old Stephen
Patek of Mesquite Nevada he was found
dead reportedly when SWAT entered his
hotel of an apparent suicide although
the details are still unclear multiple
weapons were found in the shooters hotel
room these shooters brother was
interviewed by the media and said he was
not aware of the shooter having at the
types of weapons that were reportedly
used in this event which include sort of
rapid-fire automatic firearms and police
used explosives even to get into the
hotel room of the shooter here a totally
chaotic totally terrifying and reports
of just endless people dropping dead or
injured in a crowd and it can be really
difficult to accurately assess how long
this lasted there are some eyewitnesses
who say this was not a quick event this
was something like 7 to 10 minutes and
of course we know that particularly in
these situations
eyewitness testimony can really be off
in terms of how long something went on
needless to say from the video we have
it was clearly bad police shut down the
area they urged the public to stay away
flights in and out of McCarran Airport
in Los Angeles were temporarily halted
here
just 15 seconds of audio of what the
sounded like
[Applause]
now that noise tells us that this
incident is directly related to the
types of firearms and ammunition that
the shooter had right and I'm not
talking about gun laws in this sort of
general sense of background checks or
anything like that the size of magazines
for automatic type weapons that makes a
difference this is not what someone
would be able to do these are not the
sounds of fire that you would hear if
someone had access only to the types of
firearms that were available when the
Second Amendment was written and when
people hear that gunfire how can you say
that gun laws don't make any difference
right if it were harder for this guy to
get high-capacity firearms that could be
fired at this rate of fire would he have
done just as much damage from the 32nd
floor of a hotel with a handgun you hear
this meme from the pro-gun right very
often guns don't kill people people kill
people well yes that's true
and people can kill other people far
more easily when they have access to
firearms that have that rate of fire
what about knives right you always hear
hey listen even if there weren't knives
guns available people would just do the
exact same thing except with knives this
guy from the 32nd floor of a hotel room
was going to kill 50-plus people and
injure over 400 with knives what was he
gonna toss the knives out the window and
drop them on the victims so this is as
good a time as any to talk about the gun
control aspect of this you need to be
aware that you're politicizing a tragedy
is a line that is used by the right when
they don't want to have serious
conversations it's a shut down loud line
so the right says the left whenever they
don't want to have a talk what don't
want to talk about a particular issue
the left will say that's an offensive
question to be asking right that's the
criticism from the right of the left to
shut down debate the right has their own
version of that right the right has
their own version of all forms of
political correctness they criticize the
left of this is not the time
to politicize a national tragedy they
say it on climate change after
hurricanes and they say it on gun
legislation after there are mass
shooting incidents don't fall for it
okay say the politics relate to what
took place here now the things we don't
yet know right the motive if any
according to the according to police
police aren't yet aware of what the
belief system was of this individual
there it's been designated not connected
to international terrorism hard to deny
that this is an act of domestic terror
the suspects history is being looked at
including whether he had prior
communications with police police have
already said this is not an entity along
with a woman who was allegedly in the
crowd telling people that they were
going to die and appears to have been
connected to the incident police have
said these were not known entities to us
the individual the shooter lived at a 55
Plus a sort of retirement community and
people there have been interviewed and
they said we couldn't really tell you
anything that was out of the ordinary
about this individual so we will
hopefully eventually find out what the
circumstances were the immediate
speculation has been pretty unhelpful on
both sides there are some who say listen
this was a country music concert this
guy is a violent liberal and he knew at
a country show there would be
conservative so that's why he attacked
that then there's the demographic
argument which is 64 year old white men
who have guns from a town of 18,000 it
named Mesquite Nevada are probably
right-wingers not left wingers we don't
know we don't know and the entire
speculation that is in the round they're
in it within that spectrum or outside of
it not helpful right now I'm going to be
in Las Vegas in a couple of weeks I'm
anticipating a very different security
situation and probably a different just
general atmosphere around these massive
hotel casino complexes and rightly so
after this incident I told you last week
about Secretary of Health and Human
Services Tom price his use of private
jets instead of commercial flights and
government airplanes and the pressure
just built and built over the weekend
and prices now out prices private travel
and use of military jets for these
overseas trips has cost tax
there's more than a million extra
dollars we have a quote from the White
House about the resignation where they
said Secretary of Health and Human
Services Thomas price offered his
resignation earlier today and the
president accepted it Trump had
previously said he would decide by
Friday night whether he was going to
fire price so this is basically it's a
forced resignation right this guy's use
of private planes is particularly I mean
I say it all the time in the Trump era
it's hypocritical because price was one
of these major vocal critics of wasteful
spending by the government he put 20 he
took 26 flights on charter planes since
May according to a Politico
investigation and in his resignation
letter to Donald Trump Tom Price said
that he was resigning so that the
administration can quote move forward
without further disruption somehow I
don't believe that the resignation of
Tom Price is going to stop the
disruptions that are constantly going on
within the Trump administration but for
me the big story isn't really prices
resignation specifically I mean yeah
he's a total scumbag claiming to be for
the people and wanting to put in place
replacements for Obamacare that would be
terrible for the people while spending
their tax dollars on Playa a private
plane and chartered plane travel I won't
be shedding any tears over Tom Price
having lost his job but Tom Price never
should have been Secretary of HHS to
begin with never in a million years
and in fact Tom Price resigning after a
career of saying he's all about watching
out for the people this is the first
time he's actually made a move that will
reduce government waste he's left
government himself that's the one thing
we can point to that Tom Price has done
that actually reduces government waste
and let's add to that because it's
bigger than Tom Price if a few private
jet flights are enough to get somebody
to resign why are there no repercussions
for the endless millions of dollars that
Trump is funneling into his own family
businesses and the real story is let's
look at the growing list of major Trump
resignations and endless minor Trump
resignations and sometimes they are sort
of forced resignations or firings this
is a list only of I guess the somewhat
notable ones and there's a whole other
list Preet Bharara the US attorney for
the Southern District of New York might
have been getting a little too close to
Donald Trump's businesses he was fired
by Donald Trump Stephen Bannen the top
White House propagandist not his formal
title of course but that's what I call
the guy he was probably forced to resign
by new chief of staff John Kelly James
Comey FBI director fired by Donald Trump
Mike dubbed key director of White House
communications now you might say wait a
second
it was scary Moochie scaramouche II was
fired yeah scaramouche II was in that
role after dubbed ki himself was in the
role and had resigned Boris Epstein a
trump aide also a propagandist Michael
Flynn disgraced national security
adviser forced to resign is Sebastian
Gorka the white nationalist connected
deputy assistant to Trump Trump's
personal attorney Mark Cassavetes
stepped away we know about Paul man
afford the former campaign manager and
chairman Tom Price the Secretary of
Health and Human Services as I mentioned
Reince Priebus former chief of staff
chuck rosenberg this is a new one acting
head of the DEA he's out he can't deal
with the Trump stuff
scaramouche II as you probably know of
director of White House comms
Keith Schiller Trump's longtime
bodyguard was either sort of pushed or
decided to step away Sean Spicer
a notable one White House press
secretary and Sally Yates fired Deputy
Attorney General briefly the blanket
reaction is what couldn't have happened
to nicer people but it's been 8.5 months
many more or less notable and I'm sure I
missed a bunch of these firings are also
on the list half the country thinks
there's nothing to see here right half
the country believes this is normal it's
a patriotic run-of-the-mill Republican
administration and the signal that we've
now identified if Trump says publicly
that he has someone's he has full
confidence in someone that should be a
red flag to you that that person could
be gone soon and I saw you know we joke
a lot about Trump being riddled by
scandals and firings and resignations
it's good because it prevents Trump from
being able to carry out his agenda like
it
hard to get the wall built when it's
constant scandals and investigations and
that's true but this is also an
administration that can't even get it
together to in a timely manner help our
fellow US citizens in Puerto Rico so in
a sense it's good that the Trump
administration is constantly distracted
by firings and resignations and scandals
and investigations but it also has real
impact which is that this is a totally
impotent White House now who might be
next even minuchin is a possibility he's
been involved in some of the same
taxpayer dollars for personal travel
stuff as Tom Price Jared Kushner the
heat is mounting on Jared Kushner so
those are at the top of my list but this
is actually having a real impact on
people and that's why it's not all fun
and games that Trump's administration is
scandal-ridden a send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david packard show the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Linda LaBelle Linda thank you thank
you for supporting our program we do
depend on the support of folks like
Linda and everybody else who I've
thanked over the years you can sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership endless list of great member
benefits you can also pick up a lot of
those same benefits by making a pledge
on patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and the third way to support
the show if you shop on Amazon type in
david pakman.com slash amazon into your
browser before you shop everything you
buy will then send us a little kickback
and that's very very much appreciated we
really have to come to terms and deal
with the reality that the president
donald trump is just not a good person
period and there are always ways to
write off horrifying behavior right when
he said grab him by the you-know-what
well what he meant is grab him by the
you-know-what because they let you
because you're famous so it's not really
unwanted sexual contact or when he made
fun of the disabled reporter that
insulting caricature that he did it only
seemed like he was mimicking the
reporter's specific disability but
really he wasn't it was just some
coincident right you can defend it but
the latest tweet you can defend it I
don't the latest tweets and comments
about the horrifying situation that
fellow American citizens in Puerto Rico
are suffering through right now is one
where there can be no other explanation
other than Trump is not a good person
Puerto Rico has been ravaged by the
recent hurricanes everything from power
to food to water is in short supply to
begin with Donald Trump's response was
slow week almost not there eventually
after media coverage grew around Puerto
Rico and Trump definitively figured out
or someone told him that Puerto Ricans
are American citizens he started taking
some sort of action and saying some
things that made him sound like a sort
of moderately empathetic person when
you're president of the United
States and fellow citizens are suffering
this way but this imploded over the
weekend the mayor of San Quan was
pleading for help pleading for help
and Donald Trump was golfing endless
nonprofits and activists were working
feverishly to try to not only raise
money for Puerto Rico but to figure out
how to get it where it needs to be and
start making change in Puerto Rico and
Trump was tweeting that Puerto Ricans
just want everything handed to them the
mayor of San Juan herself Carmen Yulin
Cruz speaking here we are dying here
and night to not fathom the thought that
the greatest nation in the world
cannot figure out the logistics for a
small island of a hundred miles by 35
miles long so I am asking the President
of the United States to make sure
somebody is in charge that is up to the
task of saving lives begging and
pleading and what does Trump do he takes
to Twitter to attack the mayor starting
with the mayor of San Juan who was very
complimentary only a few days ago has
now been told by the Democrats that you
must be nasty to Trump such poor
leadership ability by the mayor of San
Juan and others in Puerto Rico who were
not able to get their workers to help
they want everything to be done for them
when it should be a community effort
10,000 federal workers now on island
doing a fantastic job and then another
sort of indirect slight at the people of
Puerto Rico who I guess according to
Trump are not quote working hard when
Trump went back on Twitter and praised
the people in the US Virgin Islands
saying quote I will be going to Puerto
Rico on Tuesday with Melania will
hopefully be able to stop at the US
Virgin Islands people working hard and
what makes these tweets even worse that
Trump was once again playing golf all
weekend at his own Golf Resort in New
Jersey hanging out and funneling more
taxpayer money in
his family businesses this is a shameful
disgrace it's a shameful time for the
United States and there has to be some
component here about the stereotype of
the lazy Hispanic right I mean can any
one of us imagine Donald Trump faced
with desperation for help and aid from
for example the mayor of Colorado
Springs a white middle-aged man reacting
on Twitter that Coloradans just want
everything to be handed to them can
anyone really imagine that and of course
it's not just Puerto Ricans it's a brown
skinned Hispanic woman who's the one
saying they need help and we really need
the President to put someone in charge
of this beyond bizarre beyond
embarrassing the mayor of San Juan was
not being nasty to trump she's desperate
and making a plea for help because
people are dying and she's making plea
after plea and this really goes to
Trump's insecurities right how insecure
is Trump he must be realizing that he is
seen as incompetent and he just can't
seem to do anything right because a plea
for help from a mayor about fellow
American citizens that she represents
Trump sees the plea for help
I guess as trying to make him look bad
and he lashes out and a leaked White
House memo has exposed how the White
House has been trying to spin this White
House Homeland Security Advisor Tom
Bossert sent other staffers a list of
talking points one of those talking
points that leaked is quote the storm
caused these problems not our response
to it yeah anyway back to Trump it is
pathological narcissism but it's also
just a bad person right and recall
Donald Trump's reaction after 9/11
happened he was interviewed on wwo are
just hours after the World Trade Center
went down on 9/11 he was asked about the
fallen twin towers Trump's first comment
was that as a result of the destruction
of the Twin Towers his building on Wall
Street was now the tallest building in
the neighborhood in lower Manhattan oh
yeah and of course it's just horrible
and unbelievable what's going on that's
not a good person and and as a side note
just as a final dot at the end of this
sentence the term the in terms of the
logistics of what's going on does anyone
think that if we were in
aiding Puerto Rico militarily we
wouldn't have all the electricity that
we needed turn back on and supplies
flowing but by now but somehow we seem
unable to actually provide the help that
we need I want to add just a little more
flavor on the Trump Puerto Rico
insensitivity okay in the middle of this
horribly offensive series of faux pas
slope after faux pas Trump on Twitter
slamming the mayor of San Juan who's
pleading for help this is gonna sound
like a fake story but it's all too real
remember how I told you that Trump was
golfing at his New Jersey result resort
while the mayor of Puerto Rico was
pleading for help it turns out that
Donald Trump also handed out the trophy
at a golf tournament at one of his
resorts but what did he decide to do I
guess to show deference and caring for
the victims of the hurricane in Puerto
Rico as well as in Florida and Texas
Trump chose to dedicate a golf trophy a
meaningless symbol of privilege to the
victims of recent hurricanes in Puerto
Rico Florida and Texas here's Donald
himself on behalf of all of the people
of Texas and all of the people of if you
looked today and you see what's
happening how horrible it is but we have
it under really great control quirt oh
Rico and the people of Florida who have
really suffered over this last short
period of time with the Hurricanes I
want to just remember them and we're
going to dedicate this trophy to all of
those people that went through so much
that we love a part of our great state
really a part of our great nation you
can't even help himself he has to brag I
mean did you hearing that it's terrible
what's happening in Puerto Rico but we
have it under really great control and
here is a meaningless donation of this
trophy to the victims it's sort of like
dedicating your one hundred and fifty
dollar bone-in ribeye steak to the kids
in Africa who can't afford to eat and
might die of hunger in the next 24 hours
but at least there was one person there
who disagreed and decided to have their
voice heard someone actually heckled
Trump later in the speech yelling
something like you don't you don't give
an s about Puerto Rico
I don't know that Trump not caring about
Puerto Rico is in any way unique Trump
seems not to really care about anybody
other than the self-aggrandizement and
self enrichment of
family and also it's not Trump's trophy
to dedicate like I I mean I know I'm
getting into the weeds here but someone
else won the trophy you're supposed to
give the trophy to the person who earned
it and then they can decide whether to
dedicate it or not it's all part of the
bizarre delusions when I heard Trump
dedicated the trophy I thought oh
Trump won the golf tournament Trump won
the golf tournament and decided to
dedicate the trophy he won no he
dedicated the trophy that someone else
had won it's sort of idiocy on top of
idiocy and I can't distinguish now
between a failed presidency and some
kind of avant-garde performance art
because really that would be a much more
logical explanation than that this is
really the person that Americans elected
to be President of the United States
talk about this with me on reddit at
david pakman.com slash our edu zi team
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm pleased to welcome back to the
program longtime friend of the show bill
Scher contributing editor to Politico
magazine he's got an article from a week
or two ago called the single-payer
insanity the Democrats presidential
contenders are rushing to embrace Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all plan have they
learned nothing the headline said so
bill let's I mean I I've gotten some
emails from people who are a little
bummed out about this article and they
said you've got it you've got to figure
out exactly where bill is on those can
you first just outline for the for the
benefit of the audience what is your
personal view on single-payer versus how
does it relate to what you think is good
strategy for Democrats uh I am strongly
for universal coverage and I'm policy
agnostic how you get there okay if if I
was president and the country was 80%
for single-payer and it flew through the
Congress and landed on my desk you know
sure I'd sign that but that doesn't mean
there aren't other ways to get to
universal coverage and now we're in a
situation where we have had three
decades of painful health care political
fights yep we had the Hillary care fight
in the 90s we had the Obama care fight
in 2009-2010 we've had the Obamacare
repeal fight this year no one has come
out unscathed for any of these fights
whether you're coming from the left or
the right other from the different from
the Democratic perspective you know
Hillary Karen didn't even happen and you
lost the Congress Obamacare actually
managed to get passed but you still lost
the Congress and arguably contributed
losing the presidency and now
Republicans try to yank it back and now
are they unable to do it you literally
have the prezi united states hanging his
own senate Majority Leader and speaker
for failing to do it which could may
well jeopardize there can
troll of Congress if if this leads to a
loss of Republican turnout come 2018 so
you're James Carville had a quote
earlier this year the mover on health
care losses there's no way to propose
anything significant in health care
without there being either real real
winners or losers substantively or
perceived and the losers are the ones
that speak up the loudest and cause
political damage to be politician making
the move yeah but isn't there something
to be said for the timing I mean on the
one hand you could say hey it's great
that Bernie has now decided to propose
Medicare for all 2017 there's no shot of
that happening you've got Republicans
controlling the house the Senate and the
White House so it's a really easy
political move but what about the other
side of that which is now that there's
not actually the possibility of it
passing is it time to start getting the
idea of it into the public sort of
discourse as you point out in the
article it is something that generally
speaking more than half of the country
supports and even if you're not going to
actually legislate it because it will
never pass isn't this a good time to
start talking about it here's the
problem III with as a general matter it
is healthy to propose big ideas shape
the debate try to move the center of
political gravity your way you don't get
exactly what you lay out in the
beginning if you get something if you
get half a loaf a half is better than
nothing you know that's all generally
true what's different in this case is so
number one Democrats are expended a lot
of political capital to build the
framework of the Affordable Care Act
which has gotten us 90% of the way to
your reversal coverage and there is a
way to get to 100% with the existing
framework now mere proposing an idea
typically there's nothing there's not
necessarily a cost that comes with that
there can be a political cost if you're
proposing something that is manifestly
unpopular and therefore you will lose an
election because of that as you point
out and as
advocates point out polling wise at
least on the top line the words
single-payer I generate over fifty
percent support in some polls Medicare
for all it's even a little bit better
it's more like fifty seven percent
people who are advocates can overstate
the strength of those polls because
there are other polls that bring up
critiques that show those numbers can
swing wildly once you get into the meat
of the debate but I'm not saying that if
Democrats get behind this they are
surely to lose in 2018 or 2020 I can't I
can't prove that what I do think is very
risky and dangerous for Democrats is
raising expectations to unrealistic
levels so if Democrat let's say
Democrats win the Congress in 2018 and
they win the presidency in 2020 there
there isn't a sense of strategic
Sensibility I would argue amongst most
single graphic it's maybe some do I
generally hear from people the people
want this health care there should be no
profit in health care there's no way to
get to universal coverage with
affordable care with the Affordable Care
Act we have to do this it's a moral
imperative if people have that level of
expectation and they get a rude
awakening
come 2021 you're gonna suffer what
Republicans are suffering right now
which is recrimination you promised us
this you said you're gonna repeal
Obamacare and now you're telling me it's
too complicated well screw you
use that a guy in Alabama Luther strange
he literally voted to repeal Obamacare
and he still got attacked because the
Republicans couldn't get done Mitch
McConnell could get done you're close to
him it's your fault that could easily be
the case in 2021 if Democrats are saying
well I I said I was for single-payer but
now I know it's too complicated there's
too many transition causes too much
disruption I can't really do it there's
gonna be a price to pay if that happens
well I think that that's true but I
think that the people who now are
co-sponsoring Bernie's bill just for
example are not the more sort of
corporate centrist Democrats most likely
to take that approach in a few years but
I want to think more about now because
you said something interesting which is
you
got this infrastructure of Obamacare and
you and I both know that if it weren't
for significant obstruction from
Republicans there would actually be some
pretty specific fixes that Republicans
and Democrats could come together and do
and they would fix some of the problems
within obamacare most of which are sort
of I believe related to the fact that it
just further in grains the for-profit
health care system and the problems
within that but you and I would agree
there's fixes to Obamacare that could be
made why not consider rather than the
debate being repeal and replace
Obamacare with Trump Care 3.0 or
whichever version of the Builder is or
keep what we have now why not make the
sort of range of ideas okay well
Republicans want to repeal and replace
and 32 million people will end up
without coverage Bernie and a number of
other Democrats of co-sponsors Medicare
for all 2017 let's come to the middle
and just make a few fixes to Obamacare
like wouldn't that in some way maybe
make it more likely that the fixes to
Obamacare get done I I don't think so in
this case the the way to get to I mean
it's very hard to anything in the
current environment without my
partisanship yeah and as we know from
the past since Republicans took the
Congress in 2010 that means doing very
little there there's very little space
of common ground that you have to do
usually can't do big things with the way
things are as it stands the things that
have gotten done have gotten done
because they went below the radar
they weren't above the radar there are
fixes that could be done that if they
were interpret as a given the other side
a political victory then maybe you could
get them done once Republicans and I
think we're we're inching closer to the
point where Republicans are gonna have
to admit look Affordable Care Act is law
of the land
it is to Emes in the fabric of society
now you can't undo it without causing
massive disruption we have to accept it
as it is and now let's try to make it
work as well as well as possible if
that's not gonna happen
you know tomorrow but the farther you
get away from the Obama presidency the
firmer you get away from the irrational
spite Republican have Republicans have
towards him the closer you can get there
so I don't think having a fresh
ideological
battle over do you want government
involvement in health care or not I
don't think that that moves you
naturally towards let's have some
incremental bipartisan technical fixes I
mean the things that should be done
quite frankly are are even not that
simple let's increase the individual
mandate penalty so people aren't being
Free Riders let's find a way to empower
the independent Medicare Advisory
payments board so we have some more cost
controls let's maybe we reduce the
subsidies for those who are applying for
hardship exemptions right now those
Republican governors in their in the
more conservative states may then get
over their their spite and actually
expand Medicaid I don't think having the
single-payer argument automatically
moves you there and I think there's a
whole host of other issues that are
really on the sidelines climate
infrastructure the future of work
immigration and that's I'm glad you're
mentioning that because that's one part
of your article where you say quote
there are more pressing issues to
confront I guess I don't understand why
if you say hey our position or the
position of this group of Democrats or
whoever is that we believe the ideal
system is Medicare for all and we will
work within reason with Republicans to
improve the system we have up until such
point until Medicare for all is viable
then confront all the other issues right
it felt kind of like a nobody can walk
and chew gum at the same time type of
assertion well it's not that health care
is not pressing obviously if you don't
have health insurance or your health
insurer is insufficient that is that is
a pressing issue for you
single-payer is not a pressing policy
goal because there are other means to
get to universal coverage that I get a
lot of people are dying well if people
are dying take the fastest path to
solving that problem not the long
drawn-out protracted ideological path if
there's a lot of obvious obstacles are
gonna be in your way so and I and
there's a political argument to make
which is look Democrats can't can't run
on walkush technocratic policies it was
Mario Cuomo said you you you campaign in
poetry you govern in prose we don't
don't go campaigning and prose
I get that but campaigning on Big Ideas
you know comes with inherent
difficulties it's not like the farthest
left candy and the farthest right
candidate win every election in which
they participated in many cases they
don't so you got to pick your spots and
healthcare we have three decades of
evidence that that is a very difficult
spot to pick it's like Obama ran on
health care as a signature policy plant
in the general election no but I think
the one interesting aspect there as you
mentioned hey listen more than 90% of
voters support requiring background
checks for gun buyers yet we ended up
with a president who doesn't believe
that isn't there every indication that
people vote more on health care versus
on gun control in other words recent
Gallup poll which looks at what are the
most important vote abolition while
people may have very strong opinions on
gun control and background checks health
care always ranks much much higher in
terms of the most important issues in
deciding on who to vote for and thus if
you do find a position like health care
for all single-payer or whatever that is
palatable to people it might actually
influence voting more significantly than
the background check thing well I'm not
arguing that gun control is somehow a
magical political issue for Democrats to
stand out I did actually see a poll just
this morning that was taken in August by
I think MBC Wall Street Journal that
actually said the opposite that actually
had guns at the top of the list
interesting of things that were would
make you would shape your voting
decision I mean it wasn't 50% of its 35%
but out of the list of issues that was
the number one okay so it may just be
how you word the question or what
people's mood on a particular day yeah
so I there's clearly a single-payer
movement there's clear that it is their
top issue I don't think Bernie would
make this his number one issue if that
movement didn't exist and there's cailli
people on the conservative side who
repealing obamacare is there a top thing
so manat like I can't make the case
definitively that it's a bad political
move in a campaign I think as a policy
matter
there are intrinsic policy complications
in transitioning out of a system that
has been built over time for 70 years
you're talking about as a literal matter
I don't want to sound hyperbolic but as
a literal matter this is a hostile
government takeover of an existing
industry you can't come up with an
historical example where that has
happened in it in modern memory so the
insurance industry by definition are
literally fighting for their lives and
you might say well good you know they
they should we don't want proper health
care gonna screw them we should beat we
should we should take them out ah
evidence shows it's not that the
insurance industry is gonna buy off
Congress people and you're gonna lose or
they want to buy off Congress people you
can beat them with people power it's
that they're gonna be well resourced
they're gonna do their research they're
gonna find the weak spots in your
argument and they're and they're not
going to be undercut by a divide in
their ranks
you know we had in the Obamacare fight
the Obamacare process Obama dealt with
the insurance Lobby dealt with the drug
lobby the insurance Lobby played kind of
a double game and in the end they gave
they gave money Chamber of Commerce to
defeat it but it wasn't like the 90s
with Harry and Louise where what I mean
those Harry Louise as in the 1993 they
were issued before Bill and Hillary
wrote the bill that's how committed they
were to defeating Clinton care that
wasn't the case with Obamacare and the
drug Lobby put in millions of dollars
they brought back the Harry and Louise
actors from the 1993 ads and use them in
Pro Obamacare ads so the Chamber of
Commerce campaign was was neutralized by
that there was a divide in the corporate
community you will not see that in a
single-payer fight you will face a
unified front I can't say this with
certainty I suspect that this insertion
issue will go to other corporations and
say hey if they can take us out if you
can have a hostile government takeover
of our industry they can do it to you
too so you better get on our side on
this that is just I think you you can't
think of a more ambitious ask and to
supplants a private industry with with a
single government entity yeah so I use
don't and thinking through what that
means politically how do you answer
people's questions Oh over you for exact
here for example uh an obvious argument
as well I'm gonna raise your taxes but
you're gonna have no premiums you're
gonna have no co-pays you have no
deductibles that's a sweet deal that's
an easy argument once I articulate that
properly people are gonna get it and
they're gonna come on my side but you
did not see in Bernie's bill a provision
that spells out what those taxes are no
yeah I don't know I mean you know Bernie
said that that would be in a separate
bill and you can criticize that decision
you can criticize putting the spending
part in a different you know how you pay
for in a different bill or you could say
it it makes sense to keep the
appropriations part of it separate from
the policy part but that I mean there is
a defense for that which is yes it's not
in that bill but it will be discussed
but point taken nonetheless I mean I
think you're right that there there are
a number of pretty big matzo balls that
remain hanging out there that we sort of
have to figure out he would not have
gotten 16 Democratic co-sponsors many of
whom are potential presidential
candidates if that tax piece was in the
bill because he knows and they know that
is hard to defend and it's hard to
defend because you you can say it's
gonna be a sweet deal for you trust me
trust me that you're gonna come out
better at the end of the day but people
there is some inherent distrust the
government out there whether we like it
or not and they're gonna say how do I
know that you're telling me it's gonna
cover everything you're telling me my
costs aren't gonna go up but how do I
know that's gonna be the case ten years
after the bill passes huh and if you're
wrong if you come back to me ten years
later and say oh I'm sorry it's more
expensive than I thought well where's my
recourse you're it's it's single payer
there is no other recourse that's a lot
to ask of people who many of whom in
surveys today say I am content with my
current health care it may be that their
contempt because they haven't gone into
jam yet but nevertheless you have to get
someone to say you can't say if you like
your plan you can keep it you have to
say trust me this plan is better that is
hard politically to do if you made
politically in a campaign setting we
don't get all the details but in a
legislative setting you will get into
those details and it is tough alright
bill scher he said it all I am getting
ready for I'll just start forwarding you
emails later today bill bill scher
contributing editor to Politico magazine
thanks for talking to us about this
oh the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
interesting thing going on with
deportations of undocumented immigrants
you'll remember that our current
president promised to be the big de
Porter he'd get the country cleaned up
of the not the best people that Mexico
has been sending us law and order all of
that type of thing and it is true that
the Trump administration has been
bragging about and has been making more
arrests right immigration officials from
ice have been making more arrests for
people who are on who have immigration
status violations since he became
president of the United States but more
arrests does not mean more deportations
especially when the arrests are pretty
haphazard deportations are actually down
under Trump now I'm not complaining I'm
not passing a value judgment on this I'm
just pointing out to you that the
rhetoric has been everybody's gonna go
out and then they can come back in maybe
legally through a beautiful door in the
as yell as yet to be built wall that
Mexico will pay for but deportations are
down the numbers show that the Trump
administration is on pace for fewer
deportations in 2017 than in 2016 under
President Barack Obama and there are 43
percent more arrests so how do the
numbers add up more arrests way more
arrests but way fewer deportations the
pledge from Trump was to arrest and
deport so-called
criminal illegal aliens three million
drug dealers that Trump says are around
and gang members and other criminals who
have committed crimes in addition to
being undocumented in the United States
Isis having trouble finding them right
43 percent more arrests by ice but it's
mostly people with no criminal record
who are just in the u.s. undocumented in
addition Trump's rhetoric around
immigration has made it so that a ton of
non profits have raised way more money
in donations they are now providing pro
bono legal help to undocumented
immigrants and that is slowing down
deportation so consider the big picture
of what's happening here Trump wants to
keep us safe so he says we're gonna just
start arresting way more people and
deporting them ice rather than targeting
space
pick undocumented immigrants who have
committed violent and other crimes and
would qualify for quick deportation ice
starts haphazardly arresting everybody
with an immigration status violation it
fills up the system with people that are
low priority with deportation many of
them end up getting free legal
representation as a result of Trump's
rhetoric and then the entire law
enforcement and immigration and legal
apparatus gets gummed up because it's
full of people who have been arrested on
immigration status violation violations
but actually haven't committed any
crimes it's backwards it's a total
gongshow and if your question is well
how will the Trump administration talk
about this they'll just say Isis doing a
fantastic job tremendous really did you
know arrests are up a lot of people
didn't know that but they are we're
arresting more illegals than ever before
stunning really amazing what Barron can
do with computers they're going out and
maybe someday they'll come back in but
they're just being arrested by ice and
deportations are down if you are a
committed trumpet how do you defend this
how do you justify this and again I'm
not saying this is a good thing I'm not
saying I support the policy but if
you're a Trump pissed and you believed
what Trump was going to do how do you
defend this or do you just pretend it's
not going on let's talk a little bit
about the midterms I've talked about the
importance of the 2018 midterms so much
so that when people call in and ask me
do I think X Y or Z is a good 2020
candidate for the Democrats I say I'm
not ready to talk about that let's focus
on 2018 however we don't even have to
wait for 2018 there's 20 17 races that
we can focus on and there's an
opportunity for get-out-the-vote to turn
a major red seat blue last week I told
you Roy Moore defeated Luther strange in
the Alabama Republican primary one
storyline last week was Luther strange
was Trump's guy and right after strange
lost Trump distanced himself he deleted
tweets supportive of Luther strange and
all of a sudden Trump supports Roy Moore
okay another storyline last week was
that Roy Moore is a total lunatic having
previously said that the First Amendment
only applies to Christians and lots of
other wacky stuff hey man it's part of
the battle of ideas though spare me
right I've mentioned the name Doug Jones
for I've mentioned that Doug Jones is a
better option in Alabama he is the
Democratic challenger he supports
universal health care
he supports public schools he supports a
living wage and protecting Medicare and
equal pay for equal work and renewable
energy LGBTQ equality pretty solid
Democratic candidate the big news is
that Jones is trailing Roy Moore in
Alabama by fewer than six points it's
like five point seven or something like
that
Alabama could be in play in the Trump
era a major opportunity to turn a red
seat blue it's fifty point two percent
to forty four point five percent it's a
poll conducted by opinion savvy and
commissioned by decision desk HQ five
percent of polled voters say they're
currently undecided you need to be
working on this campaign Google get out
the vote Doug Jones Google phone Bank
for Doug Jones and you do not need to
convince any Trump lovers to vote for
Doug Jones you merely need to get people
in Alabama to vote who want to reject
the Trump agenda and want to reject this
theocratic version of Christian Sharia
that people like Roy Moore want now I I
do want to be realistic with you right
Doug Jones is a respectable person he
has well-thought-out positions Roy Moore
is a dangerous Pro Christian Sharia
lunatic who puts a religion above the
law we would imagine that in the United
States of America it would be no contest
Roy Moore would lose but this is Alabama
and part of the reason why the gap might
only be six points is that Roy Moore has
been engaged in a primary up until last
week he hasn't even really started
campaigning against Doug Jones so I
don't want to paint this as any day now
we're gonna have a democratic senator
from Alabama but what I do want to make
very clear is that this is a special
election special elections are typically
very low turnout and this is an
opportunity before the midterms before
2020 to get involved now early December
December 12th I believe is election day
in this race get involved forget about
the polls and just try to get out the
vote because there's a real opportunity
here too
a red seat blue in a state that we never
would have imagined it to be possible we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail i received about a recent
patriot mail episode by the way that was
the most interesting Patriot mail I've
ever seen on your show you should do
that you should pick one a year so this
was the best Patriot mail of the year
this guy would be good can either
freaking [ __ ] I said at this point in
time
I cannot believe anybody would still
support the incompetent illegitimate
prompt just blows my frickin mind
oh the the naivete forty percent nearly
of the country still supports Trump and
I know that that people like you and me
and and you know people that understand
what's going on we are shocked that
there are still people supporting Trump
but you've got to get over that we've
got to get over that and go to the
pragmatics of how we can actually get
people involved and voting in 2017
special elections in 2018 and ultimately
in 2020 because the guy is teetering
between 35 and 40 percent support that
is incredibly disturbing on today's
bonus show we will talk about the
Catalonian independence vote which send
it into total chaos in Spain we will
talk about new regulations on edible
marijuana in Colorado and also we have a
congressman fresh out of prison wanting
to get back into politics
yeah I'm talking about congressman
Michael Grimm those stories and more on
the bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show with david pakman.com slash
membership you can also access the bonus
show now by becoming a $5 a month patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
appreciate everybody support hoping to
have a really solid month here in
october grow our support i'm gonna have
actually something to announce
new content on the program maybe in a
week or two so all very exciting things
and I will talk to you more
it is bone shot
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you